what do they do with horses when they
die you know you can turn them to glue
you can eat them wrench the French
horses aren't any of a donkey they still
eat horses oh yeah I think certain
places in Asia like Japan still for sure
I don't still make our hosts do they I
feel like you'd come up with better ways
to make glue I know that in uh oh my god
my my wife my ex-wife who who rides she
knew a person who that's paid some crazy
amount of money for a jumper some crazy
amount of money like I don't know what's
a jumper like a socialist I mean
literally 200 or so if it's a like two
hundred thousand dollars or more right
for this course very special like
Olympic you know like and well that a
horse went missing and they found that
horse about two miles down the way in a
field and it had been butchered for its
meat yeah they these people were poor in
the area and they just killed that horse
and [ __ ] took it had no idea that I
was a regular horse that I probably
isn't yeah that's a torn if that's not a
horse then they ate him huh no they ate
that day Dave they have me for the next
year 1,200 pound animal makes sense if
you're starving or you're hungry or half
horse I've never been anywhere I've
actually eaten horse in France was it
nice it was dried they dry it and slice
it oh she said you know what you're
eating and I said what she goes horse
meat we eat everything else it's it's a
hoofed animal you would eat him out in a
wild believe me
they probably taste like elk look at
that it's pretty [ __ ] fresh yeah
chin you would [ __ ] eat that I would
yeah have you tried only if it was like
you know of course a horse is gonna die
or something like that but I wouldn't
want to eat it normally I would but if
it was at a restaurant to eat a cow yes
to be honest if I was at a restaurant
and they served it and it was it was
done well you know I mean it was taken
care of yeah yeah because what happens
with a lot of horses when they can't
jump anymore when you buy a horse for a
lot of money and then they are you
retire them well you still put them out
to pasture and they still have to live
in a stable
but they lived their life in a field
eating like horses do and then they died
but that cost some money sometimes you
still have vet bills yes well I told you
how much you don't like you could have I
said you said goo boo got it yeah you
said what do you want it would dry pick
whatever car you want to drive what do
you pick one I saw the bill for how much
was it dude yeah you said that you like
pick one pick what car what car it looks
pretty nice I know dude who spends for
his wife's horse habit and I call it a
habit he spends I think $500,000 a year
on horses just horses do they even know
them though oh yeah and if you look at
worse is on another they'd found their
property you gotta drive to protract
they told him correct so you cannot
really Lisa them well no but you you own
them and what happens is they day then
you have to pay a groomsman yeah a groom
like a groom you have to pay stable fee
you have to pay vet bills you got all
kinds of [ __ ] all kinds of weird stuff
such a and then they have such a rich
person and they have to be exercised
they have to be exercised I knew a guy
that did the horseshoes that's his
business
oh yeah he was making oh yank oh yeah a
shitload of change the shoes yes the
best the best is anytime you have an
industry like that with people who have
a lot of money you have smart people who
come in and say I'm a horse chiropractor
like this family that's a bummer have I
paid for it
no maybe I have Brendan now fight my
belt did I take my belt I'm go pick your
battles II don't know but it sure was
yeah more than that but come on dude she
or he has got a crack the horses you've
got to get the horse into place there's
all kinds of [ __ ] that goes on with
horses and it's not just that they you
know there's also magnets some to magnet
they're all kind of luck their horses
Brian yes they do but this yes they do
but they're also people that do weird
[ __ ] like this they do like magnetic
therapy oh you know it's bro science all
those
all those things that cupping you have
on you have too much money so they're
like yeah I'll do all kinds of stuff put
antennas on my washer right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]